- Dans ce quartier industriel
de Lviv, un atelier extérieur
improvisé, comme il en est
apparu un peu partout
en Ukraine.
Une énorme quantité de
bouteilles sont entassées,
non loin d'une réserve
de produits combustibles
et de quelques bouts de tissu.
Tous les ingrédients pour
assembler un cocktail Molotov.
"Il vaut mieux faire ça à
l'extérieur", dit Vlad, 18 ans.
Depuis le début de la guerre,
lui et des membres
d'une organisation étutetete
fabriquent des armes
incendiaires artisanales
et les expédient au front
à Kharkiv et Kiev.
"Elles sont destinées
aux civils qui n'ont pas
d'armes pour se défendre",
explique-t-il.
Vlad est devenu très habile.
Au plus fort de la demande,
son groupe et lui pouvaient
en produire 1500 par jour.
(fracas)
Depuis, la demande a diminué,
mais ils sont toujours prêts et
en ont des centaines en réserve.
Son équipe coordonne aussi
l'envoi de matériel humanitaire.
"Dans une guerre,
il y a la ligne de front
et la base arrière.
L'une ne peut pas fonctionner
sans l'autre, explique-t-il.
Nous sommes prêts à aider de
toutes les façons possibles."
Si des gens ordinaires veulent
faire leur part, de nombreuses
entreprises dans l'ouest
de l'Ukraine contribuent
aussi à l'effort de guerre.
Dans cet atelier de couture,
les machines résonnent
24 heures sur 24.
Les travailleurs, ici,
confectionnent des gilets pare-
balles et des ceintures pour équiper
les soldats qui sont au front.
Il y a un mois d'attente,
explique ce responsable,
nous ne prenons plus
les commandes; la demande
est trop forte."
Mais en pleine guerre,
difficile de s'approvisionner
en matières premières.
Nous avons assez de mains,
assez d'espace, mais pas
assez de tissus", explique-t-il. Ici,
les employés travaillent de longues heures avec fierté.
"Je ne peux pas tenir une arme,
dit Oksana, mais je peux aider
avec mon savoir-faire."
Elle s'inquiète pour
les militaires au front.
"Ça fait mal. Je ne suis pas
une magicienne, mais j'aimerais
arrêter cette guerre, dit-elle.
Mais d'ici là, il faut
s'accrocher."
Travail, travail,
travail, jusqu'à la fin.
Près de six semaines
après le début du conflit,
la détermination reste intacte.
Ici Louis Blouin, Lviv.